bonjour la séance est ouverte
mais chers collègues
est-ce que la connexion fonctionne
et c'est toi qui
OK
[Musique]
nous sommes très heureux d'accueillir
aujourd'hui en visioconférence depuis
Taïwan madame
ministre taïwanaise du numérique madame
la ministre je vous souhaite tout
d'abord la bienvenue même si c'est à
distance à l'Assemblée nationale et je
vous remercie au nom de tous les membres
de la commission d'enquête pour votre
disponibilité
et la rapidité avec laquelle vous avez
répondu à notre invitation dans le cas
de notre commission d'enquête sur les
ingérences étrangères qui touchent notre
pays mais qui tousse aussi l'ensemble de
démocratie dont évidemment votre pays
Taïwan
plus votre pays pardon excusez-moi
au-delà de la menace militaire qui s'est
ouvertement manifesté il y a quelques
jours qui se manifeste régulièrement
votre pays et votre peuple doivent faire
quotidiennement face à des menées
hostiles en particulier dans l'espace
numérique les capacités de réponse à ces
attaques sont souvent données en exemple
par les spécialistes y compris les
spécialistes que nous avons auditionné
c'est pour ça avec Madame la rapporteur
que nous avons souhaité vous avoir avec
nous aujourd'hui
nous serons donc très heureux madame la
ministre de vous entendre sur ces
questions de comprendre la politique qui
a été menée par votre pays et que vous
souhaitez mener par votre pays pour
assurer votre liberté votre indépendance
et la souveraineté de votre démocratie
je vous prie aussi d'accepter nos
excuses pour le retard de du début de
cette commission votre emploi du temps
est très chargé nous espérons que cela
ne mettra pas en péril je vous présente
nos excuse au nom de l'ensemble des
membres de la commission cette audition
je le précise aussi pour vous Madame la
Ministre et retransmise en direct sur le
site de l'Assemblée nationale française
l'enregistrement vidéo sera ensuite
disponible pour tous avec évidemment la
traduction pour ceux qui nous écoutent
cette commission est traduite en direct
de l'anglais vers le français par les
services de l'Assemblée nationale madame
temps je vous laisserai la parole pour
une intervention liminaire d'une dizaine
de minutes mais vous pouvez prendre
davantage de temps s'il vous semble
évidemment nécessaire pour exposer la
politique et les pratiques de du
gouvernement taïwanais et de votre
démocratie évidemment aussi pour le
précise pour ceux qui nous regardent
dans la ministre et non pas pour vous
vous êtes évidemment ministre d'un pays
souverain vous n'avez pas évidemment
apprêté serment devant notre assemblée
mais je le précise pour les citoyens
français et les médias qui nous suivent
madame la ministre je vous remercie une
nouvelle fois et je vous laisse la
parole pour votre exposé
de prendre la parole devant la
commission d'enquête sur les ingérences
étrangères de l'Assemblée nationale
française comme vous le savez Taïwan est
au premier plan mondial en matière de
démocratie numérique nous défendons
contre les intrusions de l'autoritarisme
entre 2021 et 2022
et ce un rythme deux fois plus élevé que
par le passé cela illustre l'importance
que le
au mois d'août de l'année dernière un
grand nombre d'attaques un nombre sans
précédent d'attaque des DOM ont été
menés
par 23 en une seule journée par rapport
au records précédents
en outre des affichages numériques ont
été piratés
des messages malveillants malgré ses
attaques contre notre démocratie nous
l'avons emporté
alors il ne s'agit pas là d'un événement
isolé les conditions la situation de
Taïwan n'est pas en rapport avec celle
de l'Europe le soir que le monde a
constaté la
l'importance de plus en plus grande de
la cybergère comme cela a été mis en
évidence par l'agression de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine
est un partenaire démocrate démocratique
et à ce titre elle est hautement
consciente de la menace que pose
l'expansionnisme autoritaire il a donc
proposé à l'Ukraine son aide sans aucune
incitation la France est un protéger un
appartement en Europe et dans le camp
démocratique il doit donc accélérer
renforcer ce partenariat en matière de
démocratie numérique
en effet nous sommes tous confrontés aux
mêmes difficultés
les progrès technologies afin de cons
olider son assise et de redéfinir les
normes en ligne de manipuler l'Internet
pour contrôler et pour polariser les
communautés en ligne
artificielle sont amenés à causer des
dommages et à nourrir la criminalité
mise en place un ministère des Affaires
numériques
à savoir la résilience numérique pour
tous l'idée est de permettre à tout un
chacun au pays de se remettre rapidement
de s'adapter et de tirer profit de son
expérience afin de renforcer dans un
état de santé numérique
dès la création du ministère en outre de
l'année dernière nous avons
immédiatement revu les réglementations
afin de limiter les protéines de
renforcer la sécurité des affichages
électroniques et de renforcer notre
défense contre les cyber menaces il
s'agissait là du premier document que
j'ai signé à titre essentiel
nous mettons à présent en commun les
ressources en termes de cybersécurité
aussi bien public que privé
nos infrastructures sensibles en cas
d'urgence et plus spécifiquement nous
avons construit une architecture 03 au
sein de nos organisations d'État il
s'agit là d'un élément de notre
stratégie nationale
en intégrant de nouveaux fournisseurs
satellites nous voulons nous souhaitons
veiller au maintien des communications
en cas de crise afin de maintenir la
résilience de la société et de
promouvoir des connexions avec des
alliés des amis et des partenaires de 80
du monde même dans le cas où un séisme
détruirait les câbles sous-marins et les
centres de données et bien grâce à nos
investissements dans les réseaux de
secours
nous pourrons nous pourrons
continuer à assurer ses services et cela
prouve notre engagement notre
détermination à renforcer la résilience
démocratique
nous avons également œuvré en faveur de
résonance
et nous avons mené également des projets
pour en démontrer la viabilité cela
passe par l'installation de récepteurs
dans trois sites étrangers et dans 70
sites autour de du Taïwan ainsi que dans
les îles périphériques et dans les zones
nous avons investi environ 160 millions
d'euros qui ont été alloués pour les
deux prochaines années dans ce projet
l'objectif étant de veiller à ce que les
satellites continuent de remplir le rôle
rôle tel que les vidéos conférences la
diffusion en direct etc l'idée de
maintenir la résilience numérique la
résilience d'urgence
de répondre de manière efficiente aux
différentes crises auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés quel que soit quelle
qu'elle soit que ce soit sous forme de
cyberattaque ou de catastrophes
naturelles
donner à des sociétés civile des moyens
d'agir se connectant à ce réseau
démocratique mondial pour vous donner un
exemple notre site emploi une
technologie qui s'appelle
IPS il s'agit d'une technologie
émergente de partage et données
décentralisée et démocratique afin de
résister à la sanction cela permet à
tout un chacun de contribuer à la
connectivité en cas de besoin mais
également cela nous permet de tendre la
main aux journalistes qui vivent dans
les autographies afin de veiller ce que
leur reportage c'est puisse être
conservés sans être modifié ni falsifié
la vision du ministère pour les affaires
numériques et la manière dont nous avons
intégré les principes du web 3
en utilisant des systèmes de signature
numérique pour renforcer la résilience
grâce à des technologies
d'identification publique transparentes
applicables dans le monde et un violeur
tout en renforçant notre connexion avec
nos partenaires démocratiques
objectifs et de veiller à ce que tout un
chacun puisse se connecter et créer son
propre contenu partager ses avantages et
avoir contrôle un contrôle sans limite
sur leur propre données nous avons donc
à cette dans ce but nous avons rejoint
des organisations internationales comme
le World Wild Web consertion W3C ainsi
que l'alliance Fido pour
l'identification en ligne et nous
travaillons avec nos partenaires
internationaux pour créer et promouvoir
des application s diverses en vue de
promouvoir donc des identifiants
décentralisations en avril 2022
avec la France
nous nous sommes engagés à créer
un Internet résilient pluriel et
inclusif
qui allait dans le sens du respect des
libertés de droits humains cette
déclaration sur l'avenir de l'Internet
un exemple remarquable de collaboration
transfrontalière
se déclaration en tant que partenaire
démocratique je crois que cela témoigne
de du respect que nous avons pour la
liberté la démocratie des droits humains
la règle de droit l'ordre international
nous attendons donc avec un partant
impatience de continuer à travailler
avec ses partenaires pour renforcer la
démocratie numérique et la résilience
pour finir cette approche me semble-t-il
cinq armes dans la vision que c'est fixé
le ministère ce que nous appelons
pluralité ou diversité collaborative
lorsque
les gens de tous les horizons
sont en mesure de partager et de
contribuer à des esp public numérique et
bien cela nous permet à nous de leur
donner les moyens de surmonter les
différences
et d'identifier des valeurs communes
nous avons souvent en eau difficile et
je vous donc je vous invite donc avec
instant
à partager avec Taïwan l'objectif que
nous nous sommes fixés de résilience
numérique nous devons tirer parti de
notre intelligence collective de notre
innovation et de la notre détermination
à induire un changement réel
longue vie et prospérité
merci beaucoup madame la ministre tank
pour votre exposé très précis et aussi
les messages que vous portez sur la
démocratie et les valeurs communes que
nous portons et qui tiennent évidemment
à cœur à tous les commissaires et à
l'Assemblée nationale française je pense
que nous pouvons tous cet accord pour
dire que évidemment nous partageons
votre combat pour la souveraineté et
pour le respect de vos citoyens madame
la ministre si vous le permettez j'aurai
quelques n'ont pas question mais des
demandes de précision pour mieux
comprendre votre message et de comment
vous travaillez à Taïwan et ensuite je
laisserai la parole à la rapporteur et
au commissaire présent si vous en êtes
d'accord
ma première question madame la ministre
sera vous avez au début de votre
intervention pardon
expliqué que vous étiez victime d'une
myriade d'attaque venant de l'étranger
dans le vous n'avez pas qualifié le
concept d’étranger je ne vous demande
pas de le faire ce n'est pas sauf si
vous souhaitez le préciser et que cela
évidemment c'était amplifié avec divers
événements la visite de Madame pélosi
mais aussi s'il est bien compris en
parallèle avec les événements l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie avec des
similitudes pour
pour éclairer les députés français aussi
ceux qui nous regardent est-ce que vous
pourriez expliquer une fois plus sans
compromettre évidemment la sécurité de
votre pays de votre peuple nous
expliquer comment ces attaques se
caractérisent et est-ce que sur la
période de temps que vous avez connue et
vécu évidemment à Taïwan est-ce que cela
affecte non seulement les services régal
de l'État mais aussi le quotidien des
entreprises et des citoyens autrement
dit pour les privilégiés que nous sommes
en Occident nous percevons parfois les
attaques numériques encore même si cela
peut changer notamment vers nos hôpitaux
comme quelque chose encore de virtuel
est-ce que du point de vue taïwanais et
de ce que vous avez subi subissez est-ce
que vous pouvez faire comprendre à ceux
qui nous regardent comment concrètement
vous le vivez et vous le au quotidien
s'il vous plaît
tous les jours nous faisons face à des
millions d'attaques ou d'autres
tentatives
aspiratage de l'étranger mais j'ai dit
qu'en août dernier ce nombre avait été
augmenté d'un facteur de 23
préciser qui que c'était surtout des
attaques de déni de service donc déni
d'accès à des sites Web importante
ministère d'éléphant
bureau de la présidence et ainsi de
suite ces attaques n'ont pas
ne sont pas parvenus à leur objectif de
destruction de modification de données
néanmoins elles ont créé des problèmes
de connexion donc les sites étaient
inaccessibles pendant plusieurs heures
inaccessible pour les journalistes ou
pour d'autres donc la page Web était
gelée mais en même temps il y avait
également des tableaux d'affichage qui
donne des actifs d'actualité ou des
publicités autour des gars ou dans des
petits magasins des supérettes qui ont
été hackés piratés et sur lesquels donc
on retrouvait des messages de
désinformation il y avait également la
manipulation d'informations
des messages par exemple disons que le
ministère de la Défense ou l'égard avait
été maintenant sur le contrôle d'autres
agents et lorsque
les journalistes ou les particuliers se
rendaient sur le site web pour avoir des
informations à jour bien c'est sites
étaient complètement gelé donc qu'on a
constaté des attaques coordonnées dites
hybrides si vous voulez donc j'espère
que cela répond un peu à votre question
mais
dès que nous
sommes
dès que nous avons choisi cette approche
distribuée décentralisée PFS nous avons
vu une baisse de ces attaques et en fait
ministère activé son site web à peu près
au même moment qu'il y avait les
attaques et nous n'avons subi aucune
attaque alors évidemment
il nous faisons des tests avec des
hackers bénévoles pour l'instant notre
site web n'est pas attaqué alors
maintenir un site web c'est une chose en
prendre le contrôle s'en est une autre
qu'il fallait bien sûr c'était éviter
tout problème du côté de la bourse et
l'effet a été plus négatif
deuxième question est-ce que vous
pourriez une fois plus dans la limite de
la sécurité de Taïwan expliqué le
fonctionnement des centralisé du site
que vous avez mentionné s'il est bien
compris la manière non pas dans
évidemment techniquement il fonctionne
et de donner des secrets mais de qu'on
comprenne bien une fois plus pour une
fois plus pour ceux qui nous regardent
et pour informer les députés comment il
est peut-être comment vous êtes arrivé à
cette solution comment il vous a semblé
que cette solution était la meilleure et
comment à l'épreuve des faits
effectivement il vous semble que ce
fonctionnement est le meilleur
évidemment c'est que j'ai bien compris
son principe
ordinateurs volontaires dans le monde
entier qui peuvent faire un don de te
connecter donc de bande passante voire
même d'espace de disque dur pour servir
de disque dur distribués réparti
alors bien sûr cela sert généralement à
stocker les NFC
des images produites en NFT par exemple
par exemple il y a un club
c'est une technologie bien connue
donc du web 3 par exemple en
sélectionnant cette infrastructure nous
modifions la dynamique de la défense
avant
le côté défense devait employer beaucoup
beaucoup de moyens et le côté attaque et
bien il lui suffisait de trouver une
petite faille et bien en déplaçant nos
contenus statiques sur cette plateforme
décentralisée du web 3 pour qu'une
attaque fonctionne il faudrait que tous
les ordinateurs répartis dans le monde
entier soit attaquer et soit neutraliser
et on sait que ce n'est pas possible
donc une attaque est vouée à l'échec
cette technologie nous l'avons
sélectionné non parce qu'elle est
secrète mais justement parce qu'elle est
en open source
du logiciel libre l'architecture est
ouverte et les lanceurs d'alerte et
d'autres
préfèrent ces technologies pour
préserver leur fichier parce que
justement avec ce système décentralisé
il y a on prête moins le flanc aux
attaques
merci Madame la dernière question avant
de passer la parole à Madame la
rapporteur sera sur la déclaration le
soutien que vous apportez que vous
souhaitez que vous apportions
collectivement comme démocratie à la
déclaration pour le futur d'Internet
pouvez-vous revenir sur le contenu et
les objectifs de cette déclaration en
quoi les données non seulement nos
démocraties mais en particulier
peut-être le votre pays votre nation et
d'autres pays exposés comme l'Ukraine à
des attaques non seulement quotidiennes
mais aussi dans une particulière
hostilité et d'une particulière
agressivité et question dans la question
est-ce que depuis plusieurs années ou
depuis plusieurs mois vous sentez une
meilleure collaboration entre les
démocraties entre les personnes comme
vous en charge de ces questions à
travers la démocratie pour partager les
meilleures pratiques pour sal lerter
mutuellement pour bref mieux comprendre
mieux combattre pardon ces attaques de
manière coordonnée et j'allais dire
fraternelle
pour répondre à la première question
principale la déclaration sur l'avenir
de l'Internet
et bien procède une démarche
multiparties prenantes de la gouvernance
de l'Internet et à Taïwan
nous avons agi en tant que
démocratie nous sommes une démocratie
sur la même base que la France ou
d'autres partenaires
et donc là
il s'agit d'une approche très différente
des autres organisations déclarations
multiples gouvernementales ou Taïwan
devait participer à titre d'observateur
là nous sommes membres à part entière et
puis nous pouvons résoudre ainsi des
questions très pratiques par exemple le
partage de données nous pouvons le faire
en toute confiance l'idée
c'est que tous les participants bien
croient au respect des libertés
fondamentales et des données donc
ce qu'il faut c'est que les États
expliquent comment ils manipule les
données des citoyens de manière très
transparente et cela doit se faire avec
l'aide du secteur
privé il faut pouvoir rendre des comptes
sur les algorithmes employés notamment
les modèles
de Lodge langage toutes les technologies
employées bien doivent être rendues
publiques on doit voir rendre des
comptes et nous travaillons tous autour
de d'assembler d'alignement de Léa
c'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit de
participation de collaboration autour de
nouvelles technologies et de
fixation dans certains nombres
d'attentes vis-à-vis de liens dans nos
sociétés modernes
il s'agit donc de fixer les attentes de
la part des citoyens qui serviront donc
d'orientation aux entreprises qui
développent les
c'est un moyen de régir un peu
l'interaction entre lia et l'humanité il
y a des cristes telles que crises du
climat qui sont des sujets planétaires
et
dans le cadre de cette alliance pour
l'avenir de l'Internet
et bien nous pouvons nous utiliser ces
nouvelles technologies pour mieux lutter
contre ces phénomènes
tout à fait madame la ministre je vous
remercie pour votre réponse le passe à
parole à Madame la rapporteur constance
le grip
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
madame la ministre très heureuse et très
honoré de pouvoir vous entendre avoir la
chance de vous auditionner dans cette
commission d'enquête de la semaine
nationale sur les risques les menaces
d'ingérence étrangères qui pèse sur la
démocratie française et j'en profite
comme l'a fait le président de la
commission d'enquête en moi pour vous
dire effectivement tout le soutien qui
est le mien mais plus largement de je
pense une très très grande majorité de
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale
française à la démocratie taïwanaise et
au combat que nous
devons avoir à coeur de mener ensemble
pour nos valeurs communes qui sont au
premier chef la démocratie et la liberté
et nous savons que
sort à nouveau d'un exercice
militaire renforcé menée par
l'armée de la République populaire de
Chine et que ce moment de grande tension
à nouveau
occasionné non pas de l'inquiétude je ne
saurai qualifié ainsi ce qui peut se
passer dans votre pays mais en tout cas
des des questionnements et et des
perplexités auxquelles il est important
que les démocraties comme la démocratie
française puisse
apporter des messages de réconfort et de
et de soutien je pense que c'est
important de le redire de cette manière
en ce moment
vous avez beaucoup mis l'accent sur
le
la déclaration pour l'avenir de
l'Internet consignés par ascendant de
pays dont Taïwan et la France et j'ai
trouvé très très intéressant
effectivement tout ce qui est porté par
cette par cette déclaration commune vous
avez également beaucoup mille accents
sur la transparence et je crois que
c'est par de là ce que vous menez comme
politique publique en votre qualité de
ministre en charge du numérique pour la
République de Taïwan un engagement
personnel fort si je puis dire que vous
portez de depuis longtemps
en faveur de la transparence voir d'une
forme de transparence radicale vis-à-vis
de vos concitoyens vis-à-vis de la
relation qui doit exister entre entre
l'État et et les citoyens
est-ce que vous nous en dire un tout
petit peu plus sur cette
ardente obligation de de transparence et
de ce que cela implique par exemple pour
embarquer si je puis dire les la
population taïwanaises dans cette cyber
résilience dont vous nous avez parlé
c'est-à-dire que il y a tout le temps
justement de l'information
régulière rapide immédiate totalement
transparente qui est faite sur par
exemple sur les les cyberattaques et
l'attribution des cyberattaques
nombreuses très nombreuses que subit
Taïwan est-ce qu'il y a d'autres voilà
d'autres caractéristiques que vous
pourriez avoir envie de nous préciser de
développer merci
sont des valeurs clés en effet sans
transparence
à prêter trop d'attention à la question
de la sécurité et au progrès
technologiques
qui sont dans une sorte de tension
permanente
lorsque l'on parle de l'administration
sur la sécurité c'est bien par exemple
on voit bien que différentes autorités
différents ministères peuvent être en
charge et s'il travaille de manière
isolée les uns des autres comme cela a
été le cas par exemple le début de la
pandémie et bien on peut avoir des
difficultés puisque on se retrouve dans
une situation où on doit faire des choix
entre par exemple santé publique d'un
côté respect de la vie privée de l'autre
pose des dilemmes pour les opérateurs de
politique publique et au final personne
n'est très heureux des résultats en
revanche avec la transparence si l'on
est transparent si l'on dit sans
emballage qui est responsable qui doit
faire ceci qui doit faire cela les
lobbyistes les journalistes
qui ont accès au ministère et à la
population et bien vont être en mesure
de
se faire l'écho de ce qui se passe au
sein des autorités au sein des
ministères
en d'autres termes aussi bien les gens
qui s'intéressent à l'aspect sécurité
que les gens qui s'intéressent à
l'aspect démocratique démocratie ou
liberté seront pleinement impliquées
puisqu'ils auront
une vision complète sur ce qui se passe
le renforcement des technologies peuvent
permettre de
suivre les cas contacts par exemple pour
revenir à l'exemple de la covid sans
pour autant que le respect de la vie
privée soit sacrifié en effet chacun
participe pleinement à l'élaboration des
politiques la transparence permet à
veiller à ce que chacun soit plus proche
des souffrances plus proches des
injustices et soit pleinement impliqués
dans le développement des technologies
et puis qu'il puis se à leur tour se
faire l'écho de leur propre
préoccupations
afin de promouvoir
une co-création une relation
propice à tous merci
merci
vous avez développé un discours
extrêmement positif
également sur
l'intelligence artificielle vous n'êtes
pas et les possibilités qu'offrent
l'intelligence artificielle aux
activités humaines au sens large alors
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que dans ce
vieux continent européen qui est le
nôtre le premier regard porté en tout
cas par beaucoup
des hommes et des femmes qui habitent ce
continent européen sur l'intelligence
artificielle et est un regard assez
dubitatif voire inquiet voir très très
inquiets et que l'un des premiers
réflexes que l'on peut avoir dans
les pays qui composent l'Union
européenne peut-être justement engendré
par cette première méfiance qui surgit
spontanément de vouloir réguler de
vouloir encadrer cadrer
réguler et donc je suis frappé par le
discours à la tonalité très positive et
très optimiste que vous avez y compris
sur cette nouvelle révolution
qui arrive
néanmoins comment appréhendez-vous les
dangers et les menaces qui peuvent
naître de l'application de
l'intelligence artificielle à la
fabrication
de fausses informations à la
manipulation des informations et donc à
la manipulation des citoyens et des
citoyennes à à Taïwan comme ailleurs
comment est-ce que vous appréhendez
cette menace
de modèles linguistiques et notamment
les deep fakes aussi bien en termes de
langage que d'image sont une menace
réelle pour la démocratie dans mon
propre ordinateur j'ai un module de
langage qui me permet de synthétiser à
la fois mon image et la manière dont je
m'exprime
chaque individu qui souhaite utiliser
ces outils abonne ou à mauvais escient
peuvent le faire on ne peut aucunement
les empêcher d'utiliser d'avoir recours
à ces outils qui sont en libre accès
gratuitement on n'est pas en train de
parler d'énormes au centre de données
ici on est simplement en train de parler
de
élément d'application qui rentre sur une
simple clé USB dans un simple ordinateur
il est donc extrêmement difficile
d'empêcher les technologies de se
répandre
mais par ailleurs j'ai le sentiment que
tant que l'on peut veiller à la
transparence et la responsabilité dans
la manière dont sont utilisés les
applications d'intelligence artificielle
dans la manière dont c'est langage sont
utilisés
dans la mesure où on peut promouvoir la
collaboration
je crois vraiment que ce sont des choses
que les traductions
les modules de traduction
sont un outil extrêmement précieux pour
promouvoir la compréhension parmi les
populations
vous avez par exemple
mes lunettes qui sont transparentes
d'imposer des
surveillance quelconque dans mes yeux
cassent et bien il suffira pour moi de
d'appliquer une pointe de colle pour les
réparer c'est quelque chose d'assez
simple je n'ai pas besoin de recourir à
des fabricants lointains
en d'autres termes pour suivre cette
métaphore je crois qu'il est important
que l'on puisse veiller à la
responsabilisation des fabricants et je
crois que le dialogue avec l'Union
européenne quelque chose qui doit être
réitérer dans l'ensemble du monde
merci
s'agissant des très nombreuses
cyber-attaques de toute nature qu'à
affronté Taïwan et de leur attribution
est-ce que elles sont
très très majoritairement en provenance
de la République populaire de Chine y
a-t-il des cyberattaques aussi que vous
pouvez identifier attribuer comme étant
par exemple en provenance de Corée du
Nord ou de système de hackers de
d'officine installé en Corée du Nord
voilà j'espère que ma conversation n'a
rien de
ma question pardon n'a rien
d'embarrassante mais en même temps comme
vous êtes une promotrice de la
transparence radicale je me lance
s de vitesse avec le reste du monde
passe par des câbles sous-marins
il est tout à fait évident que ces
attaques proviennent soit de l'intérieur
soit de l'extérieur il est très
difficile et très facile d'identifier
l'origine de ces attaques et de
constater que elles sortent de notre
juridictions qui lancent ces attaques
contre nous
les ordinateurs en question
n'appartiennent pas à des personnes des
individus ou des organisations qui sont
en train de mener une attaque mais qui
sont utilisés bien souvent comme des
sont employés par des tiers pour
détourner l'attention il est souvent de
fait très difficile de tracer et de
identifier très exactement d'où
proviennent les attaques à l'origine
j'entends c'est très clair dernière
question et puis peut-être que d'autres
députés et certainement vous le rend vos
interroger madame la ministre
est-ce qu'il y a pour
rendre consciente la population
taïwanaise de de la réalité des menaces
cyber qui plane quotidiennement sur
Taïwan et et pour armer aussi la
population à
prémunir sans protéger est-ce qu'il y a
peut-être brièvement
des choses que vous pouvez nous dire sur
ce qui se passe peut-être au sein des
établissements scolaires au sein
d'autres organismes pour sensibiliser
pour apprendre
très tôt peut-être aux jeunes taïwanais
et aux jeunes taïwanaises comment
comprendre comment se protéger voilà
quel est le degré de de sensibilisation
et de conscientisation de la population
et compris peut-être de la population
jeune à comprendre
[Musique]
du programme scolaire en matière
numérique et nous avions déjà à l'époque
était confrontés à une augmentation du
phénomène de désinformation et cela
avait eu une influence sur la manière
dont avait été conçue le programme
scolaire au lieu de
se concentrer sur à l'époque uniquement
des
compétences telles que la lecture etc
nous y avions ajouté un élément de
compétence numérique
l'idée est de renforcer l'esprit
critique mais si on ne fait que cela
cela n'a pas d'incidence puisque on se
contente de penser différemment or ce
que nous essayons de faire c'est de
contribuer à un réflexe critique
parmi les jeunes et à une approche
collaboration afin que les jeunes
puissent
contribuer par exemple à des éléments
comme une l'élaboration de de boîtes
d'informations qui permettent de la même
manière que d'autres outils mesurent le
qualité de l'air de mesurer la qualité
de l'information
l'idée est de s'adresser à des jeunes
voire parfois des très jeunes afin que
chacun fasse partie de la
du réflexe collectif de lutte contre la
désinformation
l'idée
sur les fake news mais de contribuer
bien au contraire à la promotion d'un
esprit critique numérique qui aura un
effet positif en matière de polarisation
et de fausses informations j'espère que
ça répond à votre question
merci Madame
s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chère Audrey je souhaitais vous
féliciter pour votre implication dans
l'Open Source étant moi-même issue du
domaine informatique et de l'Internet et
je suis impressionné par votre parcours
et votre engagement
j'avais deux questions une question en
vous appuyant sur votre pratique
générale de la transparence radicale
quels sont les solutions souvent vous
pour lutter contre les ingérences
étrangères une seconde question qui ne
touche plus particulièrement vous avez
été auditionné par la commission
d'enquête du Parlement européen G2
qu'elle menace d'un gérance européenne
vise la France et commence en prémunir
merci
le slogan de notre ministère
on doit veiller à ce que les
journalistes même les civiques y compris
les signes sur notre civique puisse
faire leur travail
en d'autres termes la bande passante est
considérée comme un droit humain en
Taïwan on doit veiller à ce que les
journalistes professionnels puissent
prospérer et puisse contribuer aux
grandes plateformes de
médias sociaux notamment Facebook nous
avons donc été pour parler des
discussions régulières afin de veiller à
ce que le journalisme
et accès à ces grandes plateformes et
que ces plateformes à leur tour
contribuent à la transformation
numérique à la transformation publique
en mettant les journalistes au premier
plan de leur système d'information
de la même manière l'engagement civique
la résilience de la société revêt une
importante une importance qui n'est pas
moindre afin que les sociétés disposent
des
nécessaire que ce soit WhatsApp en
Europe que ce soit line à Taïwan afin
que lorsque une personne est confrontée
à une désinformation à un une tentative
de piratage et bien qu'il puisse le
communiquer avec des écosystèmes
civiques qui sont dotés de personnes
d'organisation qui vont vérifier le
régime des sources des organisations
comme Chine par exemple
ou d'autres startups que des licornes
parfois ainsi que des organismes liés à
Google en d'autres termes l'ensemble
d'un écosystème qui est basé sur un
l'idée d'une société qui est mobilisée
afin de mieux collaborer pour mieux
réagir à ce que c'est un virus pour
identifier les virus et être capable de
mieux y résister
cela permet également d'identifier plus
rapidement les messages qui de devenir
Virot très rapidement l'idée est donc
non seulement de les identifier mais
également d'identifier et de créer
ensemble de manière collective des
réponses et des ripostes à de tels
attaques pourraient par exemple veiller
à ajouter en âge
des éléments puisque cela permet de
aider les autres et de protéger les
personnes auxquelles sont destinées ces
virus à mieux y résister en effet non
seulement la personne reçoit le virus
mais avec le virus elle reçoit également
la l'antidote les moyens de ne pas
répondre ce virus
merci Audrey et sur la partie de votre
audition
au niveau de l'Europe qu'avez-vous nous
dire sur sur les ingérences qui
pourraient toucher le repos est-ce que
vous avez des éléments sans trahir de
secret qui qui pourrait nous intéresser
de manière régulière je parle à des
responsables européens à divers niveaux
et par exemple je me suis
[Musique]
occupé de la traduction mandarin de 10
infos.fr et donc cela
fait
partie d'un effort collaboratif qui
concerne également la France contre la
désinformation et donc il s'agit d'une
connexion de citoyens citoyens
société civile à société civile c'est un
partage d'approche et la part la plupart
des instruments dont j'ai parlé sont
dans le domaine public
sont en open source et donc il s'agit
vraiment d'un terrain de jeu
parfaitement collaboratif
merci madame la ministre
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Madame chassagnol
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
madame la ministre je vais rejoindre mes
collègues pour vous dire l'honneur que
l'honneur qui est la possibilité de vous
auditionner aujourd'hui c'est assez
passionnant de voir à quel point on
partage évidemment ces valeurs
démocratiques sur l'intérêt de l'esprit
critique et de la coopération dans cette
lutte contre les menaces extérieures et
les risques d'ingérence je vais
rejoindre la question de Madame la
rapporteur concernant le l'éducation aux
outils numériques
excusez-moi
par rapport à la nouvelle technologie
que vous mettez en oeuvre qui
s'apparente si je comprends bien une
forme de blockchain où chacun peut
contrôler en coopérant le système est-ce
que ce système là nécessite que les que
les citoyens et un minimum de
connaissances de savoir numérique pour
être en mesure de contrôler cette
technologie de s'assurer qu'elle soit
utilisée à bon escient et est-ce que
très précisément sur les outils que vous
mettez en oeuvre il y a un besoin de
d'informations au-delà de l'information
plus générale sur l'esprit critique
vis-à-vis des outils numériques et
j'aurai une autre question un peu plus
large par rapport aux algorithmes qui
sont utilisés pour les pour les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que selon vous il est
possible de concilier à la fois
l'existence même de ces algorithmes qui
comme vous l'avez dit aussi les
manipulations de ces algorithmes peuvent
impliquer une forme de polarisation qui
a un risque aussi pour nos démocraties
que l'existence même de ces algorithmes
peut être conciliée avec la liberté
d'expression et le pluralisme
démocratique sachant à quel point les
manipulations et en tout cas les
techniques les stratégies de
déstabilisation de la part de puissance
impérialiste peuvent être massives et
peuvent être
perfectionnés et on a parfois du mal à
les aller voir à l'oeuvre en tout cas
elles sont pas toujours perceptibles
directement est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
y a il y a un risque en tant que tel
pour le pluralisme et démocratique et la
liberté d'expression voilà je vous
remercie
pour ces excellentes questions
en nous encourageons la mise en place de
technologie décentralisée parce qu'elles
sont
en open source c'est la nature des
technologies qui sous le temps de le web
Free il est donc presque impossible
d'empêcher les citoyens d'étudier le
fonctionnement voire mettre sur pied
une nouvelle merci une nouvelle version
pour la communauté dont ils font partie
ils peuvent se former à l'établissement
d'une blockchain pour leur communauté
financière par exemple et rien ne les
empêche de
faire une version
aux
objectifs plus néfastes mais puisque
tout est collaboratifs cela va en fait
dans le bon sens c'est pour cela que
nous faisons la promotion des
technologies ouvertes parce qu'en fait
cela augmente le contrôle par la société
sur ces outils cela donne un cadre à ces
interactions ensuite pour l'autre
question les algorithmes certes peuvent
polariser la société mais il y a aussi
des algorithmes
fait expressément pour des polariser
les discussions
que nous utilisons très souvent
si vous remontez mes fils Twitter vous
aurez vu que j'ai affiché une
conversation polis
pendant un sommet qui s'est tenu cette
année
je
demandais à des ex père
en a si malgré la polarisation dans ce
domaine s'il y avait des domaines
d'entente par exemple parce que est-ce
que par exemple la première priorité ne
serait pas de lutter contre la
désinformation et donc on peut parfois
identifier des valeurs communes qu'on
voit mal alors qu'elles existent et
c'est même algorithmes peuvent faire
ressortir des points d'accord
qu'on ne met pas forcément en avant
dans la conversation ordinaire et donc
si on donne aux gens le choix entre les
algorithmes la majorité des gens vont
préférer les algorithmes pros société
que antisociété dépolarisant que
polarisant
ce qu'il faut donc faire c'est de
promouvoir de faire une promotion de
algorithmes
pro société
est-ce qu'il faut c'est les mettre sur
la place publique
donner les moyens aux citoyens pour que
eux-mêmes oriente le débat public
leur donner les moyens de converser en
ligne sans qu'il y ait forcément sans
qu'il tombe sous le coup de ses
algorithmes très clivant et polarisant
merci beaucoup j'ai juste une autre
question pour pour réagir est-ce que
vous pensez qu'on devrait ou qu'on
pourrait soumettre au vote des citoyens
le type d'algorithme à utiliser dans ce
cas là pour faire société en tout cas à
utiliser sur Internet dans les
démocraties
par exemple que dans le digital market
hack de l'Union européenne
il y a des exigences d'interopérabilité
ainsi
ceux qui gère les communications
par Messenger et autres messagerie
et bien ces messageries doivent pouvoir
être
interopérable
afin que les citoyens puissent
choisir de recevoir les messages par une
autre application ou un autre
fournisseur et donc un autre algorithme
il faut donner la liberté de choisir en
tel ou tel algorithme donc telle ou
telle plateforme tout
donnant la possibilité
de mettre en communication les
plateformes on peut appeler ça
interopérabilité on peut appeler ça web
3 on peut appeler ça autre chose
ceux qui doivent guider c'est que
finalement pour revenir à mes lunettes
c'est les personnes qui parlent les
lunettes qui doivent choisir leurs
lunettes et donc les personnes qui
communiquent doivent pouvoir choisir
quel plateforme quelle application quel
fournisseur choisir
il ne doit pas être
contraint par
d'utiliser par exemple la même
application que celle dans laquelle ils
ont reçu le message il faut qu'il y ait
liberté
merci Madame la Ministre j'avais une
question complémentaire si vous le
permettez évidemment vous êtes libre de
ne pas répondre si cela une fois plus
peut compromettre votre position ma
question est simple c'est le narratifs
nos étudiants les tentatives ou les
réalités d'ingérence
étrangères nos démocraties depuis
maintenant 5 mois parmi les narratifs
des pays autoritaires ou des dictatures
il y a souvent la perception
retransmise par la désinformation et la
mauvaise information dont vous avez
parlé contre lesquels vous luttez
l'illusion qu'il y aurait que ces pays
autoritaires seraient à la fois puissant
par leur géographie par leur économie
mais aussi par leur régime autoritaire
et qu'en face les démocraties seraient
plus faibles par nature par essence
parce qu'elles sont reposent comme vous
l'a dit sur les citoyens ou qu'elle
serait faible pour diverses raisons que
je n'ai même pas envie de sont déployés
puisqu'elles sont toutes fausses mais je
trouve intéressant dans ce que vous
exposez c'est qu'au contraire vous
combattez non seulement les techniques
les techniques de d'ingérence mais aussi
le contenu
déployé par ces techniques à travers ces
techniques par la démocratie par la
transparence totale par la
décentralisation par la mobilisation de
la société civile et aussi sans faire
offense puisque la France elle-même
n'est pas un pays à la taille
géographique de la Russie de la Chine
par aussi la mobilisation d'un pays de
taille modeste mais qui tient debout et
donc le est-ce que vous concevez la
contre-offensive ou l'offensive toute
simple d'ailleurs ça n'a pas forcément à
se positionner par rapport à eux on peut
aussi mener nos combats de manière
totalement libre est-ce que vous
concevez le message que j'ai perçu comme
une totalité ou est-ce que le lien que
je viens de faire vous paraît artificiel
et bien oui
comme je l'ai dit il y a des personnes
qui vivent dans des autocraties mais qui
soutiennent taïwana on nous aidant dans
la mise en place de technologie
décentralisée
mettre en place des systèmes qui font
que leur message ne pourra pas être
modifié ou
falsifier donc beaucoup de technologie
dont nous parlons par exemple
qu'un modèle linguistique
comprime tout ce qui existe sur Internet
sur un petit disque une petite clé USB
qu'on peut faire fonctionner hors ligne
ce qui permet
d'aller faire des recherches sur un
personnage historique etc alors ce n'est
peut-être pas aussi factuellement
correct qu'un article de Wikipédia d'une
autre encyclopédie ça peut quand même
aider les gens à faire leur travail hors
ligne de manière protégée donc il existe
encore des gens dans des
des autres cassis qui
sont encore à la recherche de ces
modèles protégés
soit en se cachant derrière un VPN ou
par une autre technologie donc si nous
pouvons contribuer à ces modèles
linguistiques par exemple la France a
beaucoup
et dès à la mise en place du mode
linguistique
ouvert open science
les gens dans le monde entier ajoute
[Musique]
du contenu en mandarin et ainsi de suite
tout cela
renforce la collaboration internationale
nous protège tous de la censure donc
pour moi oui c'est de la résilience
démocratique que la mise en place de ces
systèmes décentralisés est-ce que c'est
une contrepensive et bien je pense
effectivement que c'est une excellente
description
dans aussi le narratifs que nous devons
combattre de la part des régimes
autoritaires ou des dictatures il y a
aussi y compris dans nos pays
démocratiques en tout cas pour ce qui
est de la France depuis un certain
nombre d'années un certain nombre de
personnes y compris des personnes
qualifiées provenant de milieux
académiques ou informés qui ne le font
pas d'ailleurs forcément un mauvais
escient un certain nombre de
préjugés ou de pré-requis culturel par
exemple pour la vie exposant que l'Asie
et en tout cas la zone d'influence
chinoise de la civilisation chinoise par
le confucianisme par le taoïsme par
différentes formes de bouddhistes par
les civilisés les différentes formes de
pensée qui ont irrigué et construit
cette une grande civilisations ne
seraient pas ne mènerait pas forcément à
la défense des droits humains
individuels et ni non pas non plus
forcément à la démocratie telle que nous
la concevons et nous la défendons et je
perçois que vous la défendez aussi à la
fois comme citoyenne individu citoyenne
et membres de votre gouvernement est-ce
que vous pensez aussi que dans les
tentatives d'ingérence il y a
l'utilisation de ce type de narratif et
comment le gouvernement taïwanais la
société civile taiwanaise les individus
libres qu'il la composent répondent par
ce narratif par la preuve elle-même que
Taïwan par la défense des droits humains
qu'elle assure la vitalité de sa
démocratie
contredit se narratif
[Musique]
le type de d'état de surveillance par le
haut
sont loin d'être
les propres de ces pays que vous évoquez
je ne crois pas que l'autocratie
technique consistant à surveiller le
citoyen ne sont pas l'apanage de ces
pays que vous évoquez et des cultures
que vous décrivez je crois que la
contribution de Taïwan est lié à notre
diversité nous sommes une nation de 20
les langues
nationales y compris la langue des
signes nous avons des certaines
personnes qui utilisent le kanji
certaines
le Romain l'alphabet romain nous avons
une grande diversité et cela me
semble-t-il va dans le sens de la
démocratie puisque cette démocratie est
justement un des éléments que nous
partageons tous
c'est précisément cette pluralité cette
identité transculturelle qui est notre
contribution au monde
en effet
quel que soit cette tradition que vous
évoquez quel que soit les traditions de
vous promenez et bien cela ne vous
empêche aucunement de participer
pleinement à la démocratie à Taïwan et
par ailleurs cela contribue également à
la traduction de l'idéal de droits
humains dans les traditions dont vous
pouvez provenir à titre individuel donc
cette
ce discours que vous que vous évoquez
peut-être existe mais il n'empêche il
n'est pas pour autant un incompatible
avec la démocratie bien au contraire
merci Madame la Ministre ma dernière
question sera
Taïwan c'est aussi illustré par être le
premier pays d'Asie à reconnaître les
droits des personnes LGBT
avez-vous reconnu enfin avez-vous
identifié lors de ce processus de
reconnaissance des droits à la fois par
la loi et par la Cour suprême taïwanaise
le mouvement de la société taïwanaise
vers la reconnaissance de ses droits et
de ces personnes avez-vous
identifié une forme c'est la première
fois qu'on a l'occasion d'en parler dans
cette commission et
qui me permet d'en profiter est-ce que
vous avez remarqué que si ces événements
a fait l'objet de tentative d'ingérence
particulière de régime autoritaire
puisque ces régimes autoritaires alors
avec différentes formes différentes
intensités très hostiles pour ce qui est
de la Russie
très hostile aussi pour ce qui est de la
Corée du Nord plus nuancer pour ce qui
est de la Chine mais pour l'utiliser
même si je passe sur ce commentaire
est-ce que vous avez remarqué que dans
les narratifs que vous avez affronter
est-ce qu'il y a des attaques sur cette
volonté de Taïwan et cette réalité
Taïwan de reconnaître les droits des
personnels les BTS est-ce que ça fait
partie des attaques que vous subissez ce
qui a eu un avant et un après sur ces
attaques là et aussi sans vouloir une
fois plus se mettre dans une position
délicate est-ce que les personnes
incarnant ce combat
ces combats au pluriel pardon sur Taïwan
ont été attaqués aussi par des
tentatives d'ingérence hostiles à titre
personnel ou comme représentant
gouvernementaux
je ne peux bien entendu
dire que en 2018 lorsque le référendum a
été tenu en ce qui concerne la
reconnaissance
des droits en vue de la légalisation du
mariage il y a eu cela va sans dire un
grand nombre de tentatives de
désinformation de mes informations
notamment sur les réseaux
anti-société que j'évoquais plutôt mais
il s'agissait
qui se sont exprimés par le biais de
publicité qui
[Musique]
qui aurait pour objectif ou Boré fait de
renforcer cette polarisation après tout
il n'y a aucune raison que des
puissances étrangères puissent contre
contourner la législation les locales et
un effet délétère sur ces débats sociaux
il y a eu un certain nombre de
d'auto-réglementation qui ont été mises
en place par les grandes plateformes de
réseaux sociaux
de manière à ce que l'on puisse voir qui
promouvait c'est tentative de campagne
depuis l'étranger et c'est tentatives de
publicité de façon au final à veiller à
éviter l'effet délétère encore une fois
de ces tentatives de campagne
c'est quelque chose qui a été fait à
plusieurs reprises alors je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce que vous dites
bien entendu les grands débats comme
celui qui porte sur le statut LGBTQ à a
déjà un effet de polarisation sur la
société et il me semble que nous
voulions éviter nous avons vraiment
voulu éviter que ces messages soient qui
étaient financés et promus par des
puissances étrangères nés un effet
démultiplicateur sur
Madame la rapporteur oui peut-être si ça
n'est pas trop abusé de votre temps
Madame ministre eu une dernière question
un peu plus
général sur les relations économiques
entre Taïwan et la République populaire
de Chine parce que les échanges
économiques les échanges commerciaux
sont importants et je crois même qu'ils
sont croissants est-ce que
il n'y a pas là un risque ou peut-être
est-ce un débat qui a eu lieu et puis
qui a été évacué par la société
taïwanaise mais n'y a-t-il pas là
éventuellement un risque de voir
apparaître ou se poursuivre des menaces
d'ingérence étrangères des ingérences à
travers ce développement des échanges
économiques sur des des transferts des
technologies ou des ou des choses de ce
genre ou des prises de contrôle des
entrées voilà divers et variés dans le
tissu économique taïwanais merci
thank you the wild
il a eu effectivement un débat public de
grande importance qui a eu lieu en 2014
dans la rue
les accords commerciaux
entre les deux pays il y avait été au
cœur de ce débat le consensus qui avait
été dégagé en 2014 à l'époque
c'était que la nouvelle infrastructure
4G
les vendeurs privés puisqu'en effet
lorsque l'on autorise
le secteur privé d'être impliqué et bien
cela exige des contrôles à chaque étape
mener ces évaluations de risque et bien
cela augmente considérablement le prix
de d'exploitation
ça a été vraiment un consensus très
important qui a été atteint à l'époque
en 2019 nous avons également
convenu que tout utilisation dans le
secteur privé de
logiciels ou progiciel
produit quelconque
était autorisé dans le cadre des
contrats avec le secteur public mais
cela pouvait cela devait être encadré de
manière extrêmement ferme et cela encore
une fois drainer beaucoup de
participation de la part de la CD civile
et du secteur privé
merci madame la ministre c'est avec
cette réponse que nous conclurons cette
audition je vous remercie madame la
ministre regrettant une fois plus pour
votre temps pour la précision des
réponses que vous avez apportées pour la
préciosité des informations que vous
avez partagées avec nous pour la vision
aussi que cette que ces informations
portent pour la défense de nos
démocraties et de nos valeurs communes
permettez-moi aussi à titre individuel
et je pense que bon de la Commission de
m'en voudront pas de saluer votre
parcours individuel le courage et la
dignité avec laquelle vous vivez votre
vie et l'inspiration que cela représente
pour des millions en particulier des
millions de jeunes à travers le monde et
au-delà de nos différences culturelles
je vous remercie encore madame la
ministre je remercie les services de
l'Assemblée je remercie madame la
Première secrétaire de la représentation
de Taïwan en France Merci
l'administration et la séance